this is a fox news alert
now just breaking moments ago axios
reports that president trump has told
multiple confidants
he plans to pardon michael flynn will
continue following the story throughout
the hour
but first joe biden tonight is signaling
a return
of the washington swamp picking a wave
of establishment figures to staff his
administration
for example national security adviser
pick
jake sullivan defended the debunked
dirty steel dossier as quote
perfectly appropriate and secretary of
state pick tony blinken
actually opposed a terrorist label for
iran's
revolutionary guard a potential sign of
a softer stance towards tehran
and get this according to new state
department documents
after joining barisma holdings hunter
biden
in a 2015 request
he wanted a one-on-one meeting with
blinken highlighting yet another
potential conflict of interest stemming
from hunter's nefarious dealings
overseas
but of course democrats and the bob in
the media can't help but
swoon over the return of the swamp even
comparing biden's cabinet picks to
superheroes seriously watch this
the other thing i'll just say is i was
talking to a democrat who just said this
also felt like the avengers it felt like
we're being rescued from this this
craziness that we've all lived through
from the last four years and now
here are the superheroes to come and
save us all
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah but we're also
learning tonight that biden's department
of homeland security pick alejandro
mayarkas
came under fire in an obama era
inspector general report
for intervening to help democrat linked
foreign investors
in the eb-5 visa program and rounding
out biden's picks
is failed iran negotiator john kerry
who's been tapped
as what's being called a climate envoy
whatever that means
so ask yourself is the democrats bench
really that thin
that joe biden has to reach into the
recycling bin
and pick from the same failed group of
establishment leftists to fill out his
administration
or are democrats and the deep states so
aligned
that they can't be separated because
what's clearer than ever tonight is that
joe biden and company are committed to
selling
out the to the swamp and abandoning the
president's
america first foreign policy and perhaps
no one summed it up better than senator
marco rubio who tweeted
quote biden's cabinet picks went to ivy
league schools
have strong resumes attended all the
right conferences
and will be polite and orderly
caretakers
of america's decline